what's going on there reject nation greg
greg
here come on i'm going to kill you
greg and john here today to watch the
boys season 3 episode 7. uh firstly i
just want to say thank you to all who
have joined us on this journey the boys
is one of my all-time favorite shows so
thank you guys very much and thank you
to all who bear with us on whenever we
have to blur stuff out i know appreciate
the understanding especially with the
last episode but guys if you're here
please leave a like that would be
insanely appreciated and also leave your
thoughts down below what you thought
about this episode and subscribe and
click the notification bell to get
notified when our reaction to the finale
is up next week right right there we go
here we go here we're going to be
covering stranger things we're probably
filming
right now we're editing about the time
this video is up so keep a lookout for
that and uh full-length watch-alongs
where you sync up with the time code
with us uh over over at why can't i
speak or over at our patreon page for
super sexy rejects cover a whole bunch
of shows over there where at the same
tier you get the options for reaction
highlights and watch-alongs included for
many shows actually and lastly thank you
to them prepper boys for helping us edit
down these highlights but the real
lastly is i'm always forgetting thank
you to storyblocks for partnering up
with us as we've been covering the boys
because we never know which ones are
gonna get us some yellow dollar bill
signs more often than not with this
series so you have saved us in in in
times of demonetization so thank you all
let's get to it
and the soldier boy thing really takes
the cake he died in 84. she is trying to
incite a panic i wonder if starlight's
actions could be considered treason me
too so
another woman scorned after homelander
jilted her or is she trying to change
the subject from what her ties with this
woman
uh oh notorious human trafficking ring
connect the dots cameron if you want to
be
living a king's life
never make a pretty woman your wife now
all you have to do is just what i say
i don't even know what that's parody
tell us in the comments come on soldier
boy was a hero right
i mean
he stormed normandy
yeah he did two weeks after d-day for
the photo-op
what
oh yep
oh [ __ ] me is he still ah
oh oh golly women they're like fine wine
okay the older they get the more
delicious but the drier
oh my god my storm's not crazy
he's bipolar he's bipolar yeah
i could talk to him lithium
prescriptions aren't that common
i mean i doubt he's making it maybe
if we look at the cabins and then check
the little pharmacies
yeah
good teamwork
no it's funny you're the new mother's
milk
butcher and soldier boy where are they
is that concealer
do you have a bruise
the ones that survived are done they're
powerless
do you understand
that could happen to any one of us
that's the difference between you and me
you need to be a soup
can you imagine how perfect our kids
would be sublime
no kid of mine i never know a room like
this tell you that
just so you
know i'll [ __ ] shatter whatever you
try to stick up there me oh my god
i respect what you are even if you don't
i would never force myself on you
oh
what you are but i am gonna harvest your
eggs that way if god forbid you do die
whether by accident or choice you'll die
knowing that the very best of you
carries on oh my god i'm not letting you
live
i'm keeping you alive
still a top three day
in my life
because today is the day i saw you
scared
[Laughter]
it is pretty satisfying
that's a good threatening line though it
is i'm not letting you live i'm keeping
you a lot oh good writing
do you mind telling us what we're
walking into here
all you got to know is if he tries to
make eye contact with you
close your eyes
or what just don't make eye contact with
him
then you got nothing to worry about you
can be more specific man don't broadcast
your thoughts or something
icky
where's he hiding out at it's willy's
wonderland
[Laughter]
i'd watch black noir in that movie
oh yes
yes
i don't know where this is going but i'm
looking forward to it
we're your best pals aren't we
we got you through that erection in the
seventh grade that hard rock cafe
massacre and lagos we'll get you through
this too together
[Music]
wow he's crazier and more sensitive than
i realized
the [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
oh don't look at his eyes
no
oh damn so your whole life flashes
before your eyes oh you get transported
oh he's gonna see his little brother
trapped him in an endless nightmare
until he dies of terminal dehydration if
we grab mindstorm we make him help
butcher no and then and then you can
kill him then you can go to town on them
man i don't give a [ __ ] if you can act
hysterical i'm going to slap you like
i'm connery
it's like a line dean would say yeah it
really is
where is he
lenny it's okay
when did you have your first drink
right now
oh my your bad influence starlight how
could you corrupt her like this she was
innocent
what about it
she needs her powers back
you know that i can't go to the tower
even if i could this would be such a bad
idea gotta protect frenchie
i've thought the nazis you want to know
what i do when i'm sad or scared
[ __ ] nothing
because i'm not a [ __ ] [ __ ]
don't say it huey
you didn't storm [ __ ] your whole
marlboro man act
it's [ __ ] crap
and i'm oh yep
dude
come on huey you're smarter than that
found out i'm gonna be on hannity
tonight
hannity you are yeah it's a big deal
kevin okay so we need to go over
everything okay hey i got us this far
didn't i
yeah you got us this far
well we both know that our marriage
sex life has gotten a little
vanilla
so maybe oh
it's time we branch out bring some fish
into the bedroom yeah
introduce a new partner just to spice
things up a little bit
like bring homelander in yeah that'll be
good is there anyone you had in mind
well i'd like to introduce you to
someone oh
okay
no
i don't want to
do that
cassandra i need this
oh my god no way
yes
of course
ambrosia says she wants to taste you
no no okay i'm out i'm out no i'm i'm
done i'm done whoa honey are you okay
what's wrong you want me to [ __ ] a a
[ __ ] fish oh hey one she's a mollusk
i have given up
a year of my life for you i gave up my
tenure at vassar i i've propped you up i
have steered your comeback and this
this is how you repay me you propped me
up and you kind of come back let's see
how well you do without me i'll be great
without you i thought you overnoting me
all the [ __ ] time you're an idiot
kevin then why did dave eggerstein have
a formidable intellect huh
formidable intellect
i looked at what formidable means and
next i'm looking up intellect
you're late we started at three i really
wanted that movie the hell are you
talking about i just got off the phone
with my manager
it's a no-go on beverly hills cop oh
why would you say all those horrible
things about me to don
simpson's the guy's supposed to be funny
you're not funny well i could have been
you're not good enough now shut your
cockhole and get to work
you're not a movie star
you're not [ __ ] i see you getting out of
line again trying to move on up i will
put you in the [ __ ] ground understood
yeah soldier boy's a jerk yeah
especially as a bird
you're a smart boy
i just hate for you to turn out like him
oh no way did he really do that oh my
god
oh [ __ ]
wow
don't you listen to him
time should we listen to that worthless
number shot
not a bleeding word
oh and he's bringing huey along with all
this too
you folks need some help yes yes please
okay well it's not safe there's a
fugitive in the area you should get out
of here before you get hurt i don't
suppose either you know engines oh look
oh i'd appreciate that very much oh no
cars i've changed so where you guys
headed we're just on our way to uh
samaritan's embrace retreat over there
in danville
no
this is my storm's emo he brainwashed
him that priest was gonna shank us and
she will too everyone's coming for us
every one and every day no no no you
have ptsd
you're a ptsd and you are super [ __ ]
stoned does he understand the concept of
ptsd i don't think so
if there's one thing i know
oh [ __ ]
stay still
oh my god
no
hard pass on this exorcist [ __ ]
what's black and white and red all over
okay first off
i don't have shell shock [ __ ] you
he's so good in this role now she wants
to take me down why because with me out
of the way there is no one who can stop
her no one and she knows it no change
exactly
you think the media is going to report
on that no no no no no of course not
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my god put him away man
oh are you going to get that milk
oh christ
christ jesus
just go live on a farm dude
let's get breakfast did we
nope
nope uh she's in pain
so i tried to help
i think you just spent the last 20
minutes ranting about starlight instead
of talking up the next president of the
united states
your homelander
button your [ __ ] up you're flailing this
whole [ __ ] scene right here
you help me out
with one small favor
and i help you
where did you get this
[Music]
damn
aoc
he lives you're awake
fantastic
oh and just who you want to see
soldier boy
murdered blue hawk right in front of you
you tried to save bluehawk of course
but
must have been awful for you ah dude
don't don't do it
yeah
it seemed like you two were on your way
to a healing place
which is why you're gonna love this blue
hawk will live on
because we gave you his heart
ah
no
way i don't believe it that is so messed
up
we're gonna get you back in your old
suit we're gonna get you out there asap
you're okay talking [ __ ] about starlight
when a track coach we're thinking tom
hanks teaches you a more civilized way
not at all how that happened my
brother's my coach we're out to sir
julian fellows to write so no i'm not
doing this you're gonna love it anyway i
gotta bounce but the a train's back baby
right that's your oh
yeah
what if miles morales was the mighty
thor
damn
heart
[ __ ]
huh
guess you
he's gonna kick the [ __ ] out of that guy
oh
you still hurt
i'm still high
it's okay
just move
oh no
i knew it was coming
you can walk away you and me
we go together after now say you're
freed on your humanitarian you have it
thought you would say that
dear frenchie
i copied this from annie
i wanted to use my powers to do good
to fight for the ones i love
i almost lost frenchie because i
couldn't fight
i can risk that again
[Music]
oh my god please don't die
please
if this is what it takes
[Music]
[Music]
yeah real hero
i love them so much i'm really worried
they're going to die one of them is so
worried about it
oh it's the cologne version of v
damn you put on a wig annie
jesus christ
good luck irving
can you please stop eating those in
front of me i'm allergic
the [ __ ] is this something we should
have done a long time ago
wow
wow
oh
damn he survived that yeah like
this is some tough stuff i know
but when you gave him to the russians
you knew soldier boy would come back one
day you need to
face him no crap
bravery isn't having no fear bravery is
having fear but you did
do it anyway
[Music]
please don't die black joy
me worried for everyone
marvin what are you doing here you okay
with this what he took her to a homeland
a rally does he have a gun you took her
where it's fine no it is not fine you
didn't ask me do you have any idea what
kind of danger you put my baby girl in
there's no danger he's a [ __ ]
psychopath worse than starlight
she's trafficking kids her emails
if you want to risk your life fine have
at it but not with my baby girl
you're not her father someone's got to
be
there it is
todd you killed him
[Music]
hey when the truth comes out about
homelander you're gonna forgive your dad
all right oh yeah
todd's gonna feel real stupid then
here she is
god damn it you're gonna recant
everything you said it was a tragic
cocktail of heartbreak zoloft in despair
you regret any harm that your lies have
caused bought
or me but
me in particular
yep
you want to hear my counter please don't
die
i saw it the night that you killed
supersonic you know what i remember from
that night i remember what i told you
would happen to huey
you walk
that's next
now that you've told my
190 million
everybody that's me
that's supposed to record us when we're
running lines
phone is the ultimate weapon [ __ ]
[Music]
um
nothing never happened to trump though
when you did that
no such catharsis on this time
[ __ ]
oh jesus i'm begging you
please wake up my friend that guy's a
piece of [ __ ] it doesn't matter i i
don't want to be someone who leaves
people behind i want to be someone who
saves his family oh
he's family
please wake him up no no way i can get
you out of here if you just
please
please wake him up
i'll teleport you away oh my god the
longer you take soldier boy's going to
get there
maybe if i'm gone he'll leave you be you
stupid [ __ ] tweet don't you leave him
i can't go
it ain't my job to look after you
don't be such a [ __ ] puff all your
life
[ __ ] knew what he'd do
it's your fault
don't say that this that's not truer i'm
not a bastard
you always have been
cause anyone has ever loved you you end
up getting them killed don't you
no
[Music]
oh my god soldier boy's gonna show up
i'm so [ __ ] sorry sorry for what wow
it's okay butcher it's okay
you're all right
hey soldier boy's gonna get him
right right yeah okay
deal's a deal where are we headed whoa
there it is there it is oh [ __ ] oh
that's so gross wow oh my god
oh
[Music]
now here's where the divide comes in no
god no
no no
they gave me the green light why would
they do that
what that's impossible
oh
oh god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god
sean walker us agent
[Music]
is he crying over what homelander
learned yeah what a
soldier
yeah
can't believe they do whatever they did
it turned your brain into [ __ ] swiss
cheese so please be honest with me and
tell me how many doses have you taken
just a couple
three to five doses kills you
you need to tell huey
yeah yeah i will
it's the tempe
what about it we've got a swing by the
office and get some more oh no
come on man
what did soldier point learn whatever it
was it sounded impossible homelander is
better
i'm gonna save huey
even if he doesn't want me to
[Music]
god i wish i had compound v
so cool to have powers that's
a lot of what i've picked up from this
show yeah that's always a good thing yep
feel his arms one last time
before they feel like bendy straws again
[Music]
oh please work
please
oh
i'm so nervous right now
wow
did the trick
you have a call
he says he's well he's claiming to be
soldier boy
oh i get called into vocal bomb's lab
for an experiment some
[ __ ] about genetics what i beat my meat
into a cup
turns out
made a kid
oh no no
no
no
you know what the [ __ ] of it is
if they just kept me around
i'd have let you take the spotlight
what father wouldn't want that for
i don't believe it
that is insane
oh my god
no
no no no who's your daddy
wow
wow
holy moly that is a plot twist yeah i
did not see that coming
i did not see that coming
christ
whoa
papa can you hear me
you know it doesn't have the um
exciting like fight factor of uh you
know watching
homelander
versing
you know the
butcher huey and soldier boy but i i
think i think i like that episode more
i think i might have
it's further down the spiral uh you know
it's interesting they've they've mixed
in the drama this season in a very
interesting
way and uh
yeah everyone's trying to protect their
family today yeah it's like it's not as
exciting as the hirogasm episode but
there's there was something really
compelling about the drama throughout
that i thought was very uh
very much gravitated towards yeah too
soon to tell could be you know recent
bias
yeah
well we we got to see the deep have sex
with an octopus so you know there's some
craziness in this episode too
cartoons coming to life you know filling
in some of the gaps
no one's ever going to be down for that
[Music]
not someone else believe me i've tried
yeah
it doesn't work one fetish no one
actually has
rule 34 broken
all right well that was um that was
excellent that was sorry before we talk
more about this
word from our sponsor who has saved us
in many videos trouble
thank you to storyblocks for sponsoring
this video being the cinematic artisans
we obviously are we are always in search
of ways to make our videos look better
faster and most of all for cheap cheap
is good and if you're a content creator
or filmmaker or anything in between
you're probably in a similar position
it's tough to get your content looking
as good as it can be without breaking
the bank or burning yourself out in the
process which is why i heavily encourage
you guys to check out what storyblocks
has to offer cheap is good do you feel
like this is their way of telling us
that the videos could be looking better
yes whether it's the credibility of an
exotic establishing shot the soothing
comfort of the perfect music bed or just
the satisfaction of increasing your
graphical capability storybox has an
incredibly inclusive and diverse library
of faces places sounds titles
transitions filters and effects and more
over a million assets royalty free and
available for personal and commercial
use with your membership sounds so
affordable this is quite affordable they
have multiple subscription levels to
suit your exact needs whether you're an
independent indie solo creator or a
whole team so if you want to learn more
head on down to our link in the
description box and get started that's
at storyblocks.com
slash rejects now back to the video
i had a feeling the
mindstorm
yeah some something like that had a
feeling he would die
um
only because that image from the trailer
kept coming into my freaking brain
of soldier just specifically the thought
that that they showed in the trailer and
pounding down the grass i'm like that
looks like it's this episode probably
these here woods
yeah but i was like i gotta hope it
doesn't but uh yeah
there's so much to love about this uh so
far i mean
like jensen ackles is just knocking it
out of the park
and a lot of ways when you find out this
twist of like he's the father
of soldier boy
in so many ways you're like
this
is so it's so twisted it's like could be
the perfect relationship that a
homelander could have ever asked more to
have this guy
as his dad like who better to identify
with and to show you the ropes than
someone who's confident in these old
values yeah don't apply for today is my
chance
uh it is it is like
that is wonderfully woven i don't know
if it's like that in the comics um but
in terms of storytelling for the show
that's a mind blower right there like
it's it's so much the the possibilities
and and now it makes me hope more than
ever that they keep soldier boy alive
yeah that they don't kill him off
because i mean jensen ackles is just
doing an
excellent job like truly an excellent
job
and
like he's he's like
he's kind of scary you know and it would
make he's unhinged in in other ways that
and you know but he also i like i really
like that scene with the priest and the
nun
because you do believe huey that
dude no
she's being paranoid it might be the
drugs it's whatever's happening in your
mind he finds out he's curious
oh yeah this guy's he actually is
because as much as there's a whole thing
about how he didn't actually storm
normandy you know that that was all just
a front
at the same time you do see that but he
he is lethal and he can kill anyone and
he's a good soldier he's a good warrior
yeah and uh he knows how to intimidate
and uh i think
i think uh you know he's there's
trying to figure out what like what
makes him likeable even though jensen
knackles doesn't
try to make this guy likeable i yeah
something about just the confidence or
you know i don't know what it is yeah
it's like the calmness
with which he does most things not
everything but there's like a certain
level of like yeah he just seems so like
assured and steady and it also seems
like if you don't piss him off he'll
probably be fine unless you're
you know somebody that society back when
he around didn't accept so much it's
it's weird yeah it's it's i i wonder how
i would feel if i had never seen jensen
ackles on supernatural but part of it is
like i really have
been enjoying the subtle difference of
character because he does really feel
like somebody out of that time is
somebody who is that sort of loner
who
you know is very much an archetypical
man but who probably does have some
issues but not in the way like a vietnam
veteran has like like you know uh
if he he feels very of that great war
you know world war ii sort of era
and uh i feel like there's maybe
something that comes with that that is
just a bit homey or quaint when it's not
the ugly parts of it yeah or something
because yeah he just really inhabits it
so well and you know obviously you have
like chris evans to bounce off of
because obviously this is a riff on
captain america and the comics and blah
blah but i i feel like there's something
just so gratifying and so rich about
what he does and and the fact that it is
kind of perfect casting
but that he's also really able to bring
these
layers to it and and and yeah you really
feel i think the
the sort of i don't know there's
something like really
uh authentic feeling to me about how
kind of hard to tell where his
allegiance will ultimately lie and how
much on the same side you can be with
him yeah
um but yeah i mean the interplay with
with
him and butcher and huey but then to go
one step further and take butcher out of
the mix and just him and huey i thought
was was
so fun to watch well we don't really
know yet
how much the
the fame and all that matters to him
right now
yeah you know whereas like homelander
thrives so much off of that on the image
where it's like yeah he you know he
cares about that or at least he did care
about that but who is he now
like what is the soldier boy of today
the kind of guy who would give a [ __ ]
about that or would he just want to be
like you're my kid i'm on your side yeah
because you could totally see it it
seemed like inevitable that there's
gonna be something that happens that
makes them team up i did not see that
twist coming
and uh it seems like there were these
some seeds planted definitely some seeds
plant but it seems like there'd be some
something planted that would allude to
that in some way but what you know like
you got some little subtle things that
make you look back of like homelander
revealing that you were my hero i
watched all of your movies and that hey
like um you know stan edgar and the
flashbacks of the the animated version
of black noir's memories saying that
there's a baby and uh thinks it'll be
better than
than um soldier boy it's just like
there's some things that make you they
could have made did you guys ever anyone
in the comments did you guys honestly
ever guess that that might be the twist
because that is a hell of a twist to me
and it just creates such a positive
fascinating complexity and like what
direction will they go in the finale
like what are they gonna do now that is
such a great groundwork for a finale
where you're like i have no clue what's
gonna happen
i have no clue other than the fact that
it seems like they might team up or
soldier boy still might want to take him
out or homelanders still might want to
take him out but either way it creates a
nuance i did just it was i could not
anticipate and uh
i respect the hell out of that um so
much because this season's got me on
edge like oh yeah i think that's why i
like this more because
i i'm just so tense
the whole time i'm watching it and and i
don't recall being like this like
shoulder shrugging the whole time of
like i could feel the tension in my
shoulders that i'm so worried that's
people i care about are are gonna die at
some point or there's something even
like todd and
and and and mm i kept thinking like does
todd have a gun like this yeah i was
going
it really feels again like anything
could happen and it it's
in a way that makes it
i don't know i'm pulled into the point
where i'm not sitting there trying to
predict things but at the same time it
also isn't yeah raising these obvious
things where i'm like oh this is
probably coming or that's probably
coming like it does feel dangerous and
it does feel like
you can't really trust anybody you can't
talk too loud like they've done a really
nice job at developing these stakes and
two i think it's good that they temper
the morality
with things like what happened with um
uh you know mind
wave or whatever his name was
where it's like you know you have huey
and it's such a narrative convention for
it's like yeah he makes him this promise
and it is a merciful promise and it's
well within huey's character but
it goes so poorly and i mean it's not
that one of the main characters got
killed this guy just showed up this
episode for the most part and
you know is now dead but at the same
time that moment made things feel
unpredictable from a dramatic sense
yeah you assume that no he was gonna get
he was gonna make good on this and
that's gonna make things way worse for
the home uh you know for the uh soldier
boy story whereas now i'm like i don't
even know where that is i'm like
because he just you know murked the guy
on the spot i didn't seem like he really
stopped to listen to what they were
doing or talking about
so it's like i could imagine some
version of this uneasy alliance with
huey and butcher continuing i could also
imagine it going completely awry and i
love that you know each episode they'd
managed to cultivate that quality or
even with kimiko and frenchie every time
we see them it's like i'm so afraid
someone is gonna you know spray bullets
through the room or one of them's gonna
explode or something like when they put
it when she took the v again i was like
oh god please don't do something
horrific right now because yeah
everything feels volatile and alive i
don't know if this is intentional but
this is more of like the kind of
commentary that i usually like from the
boys
because like we had like one nitpick
about the whole thing with uh a train
and blue hawk and the the scene where or
the [ __ ] show went down where it seemed
like it was just a little too overt for
our tastes
um
it was the
it just it seemed like crazy timing
right now with
um
you know what's been going on in america
lately women's choices of what to do
with their bodies
so it's fascinating to have this thing
with kimiko who has his character arc of
someone who's always felt like
you know cursed and ashamed of who and
what she is
and a big part of this is
her deciding what to do with her powers
and and the choice to put
it back inside of her and that's her
choice of what to do with her body
and it didn't sound like
political commentary women are allowed
to do what they want they should be
allowed to do what they want with their
bodies it's their choice but then when i
you know when the episode ends and i
pause thinking i'm like oh that's kind
of like what they're well i don't know
if that's the intention of this place
what i'm just getting the conversation
yeah well and if you look across the
episode then you have queen maeve who
stripped
is
being
bodily autonomy we're gonna harvest your
eggs and also though at the same breath
her
taking the alternate choice of i cannot
wait until i am free of this i choose to
give it up you know they shot this
episode two uh two days ago yeah
in america slow down
uh yeah i really like that because i
like i like how it just feeds into the
character arcs for them and even for
maeve who who has not had much screen
time this season but you know as someone
who has uh been so afraid
in the last couple of seasons and then
slowly found the strength to come out um
at the end
didn't mean the gay thing but sure why
not she did
um
not by her choice
and but the
the at the end of the second season and
here you know it seemed i like the
mislead of like you see her sword
training she's practicing gearing up
ready for battle and and that's not all
what's happening when she is learning
instead of like playing some sneak
attack maneuver
you know kind of like what payback did
to soldier boy
she's
just unafraid now like she could die ed
by anything she says she could just get
anything wrong like she could say the
wrong thing to set off homeland or to
laser her face
and
she doesn't care anymore like she's
she's already in her own mind sort of
one just by
the sheer fact that homeland or she gets
to witness him being afraid and and
being weak
and i i like that they've allowed her
character to go down that path too so
it's really it's really cool what
they've been doing with with the arcs of
of everyone here and then also watching
the turmoil they go through because
even with butcher you know i like that
they were
correlating past memories to scenes from
other episodes not from this season yeah
so i don't know like how much of the
backstory like these specific core
memories that butcher had
were always
part of the writing were always there
like of course it was always implied
especially with the second season
bringing up lenny getting the father
into the equation having the
confrontation with him of course that
was always there
it's just these specific memories that
do mirror very specific sequences from
moments from season one like when he's
beating i forget haley joel lostman's
character name oh yeah yeah but when
he's beating him in the bathroom or when
he when he hits huey in season two
um or even or even like the fact of how
he you know tries to get rid of huey in
a lot of ways is
like or abandoned huey is like how he
abandoned his brother so i think the
correlations the connection the the
connective tissues that they they strung
together from not just because it's easy
to kind of just pull from this season
usually when you do some type of memory
[ __ ] like that but the way the editing
worked and then to pull from those
moments i thought was really neat
because it does make it feel like it was
always intentional whether it was or not
it at least feels like it was those
scenes were always intentional to those
core memories yeah absolutely and i
think it's a really it's an it's a nifty
choice
as a way to humanize a character
and to dig below the surface without
feeling like you lost the character or
something like that because especially
butcher i feel like you know the part of
the charm and part of the fun is because
of how high those walls are yeah and so
yeah i thought this was a nicely
oriented i mean it's a harsh
story say that word anymore that's
racist oh i'm sorry
a nicely chinese way to do that
[Laughter]
it was a nicely uh uh uh it was a
conscientiously considered way of
plopping that device into the story and
uh and
yeah it's like it it's it's great
because it's in the moment in reality
it's like oh crap this is a wrench we
didn't account for but also like it it
really is
hard to watch him go through that
continually and to see the way that he
breaks down over time and i think carl
urban you know he's so much like there's
all tons and tons and tons of praise and
love for his performance on this show
but i thought here
it really underpinned how he's so great
because it's in those little in between
nuance moments like when he's
having that whole reverie at the end
when he's standing there considering
everything that's just happened
soldier boys in the next room he gets
the call from annie and you just watch
what's happening in his face as he's
trying to do the right thing but he just
can't
fully connect to making the progress and
it's there's just yeah i was like again
the show has all the pulp and all this
fun enjoyable craziness but also they
know really well how to you know
punch the feels in a way that doesn't
feel cloying or cheap or you know i've
seen this a thousand times before and i
mean we have seen stories like this
before but it feels authentic to this
character well he i mean he's always
been um
i guess the difference is is like how he
just didn't end up like a murderous
monster is
he a lot of that is stemmed from him
also simultaneously
being a protector yeah because he was
always a protector of his younger
brother
so that's
he's always kind of been like a
and there's always been a monster inside
this guy that's also been a hero
simultaneously yeah yeah so i like the
gray that's painted there
and even if what felt like a more
realistic choice is you know you you
think after seeing like you know
flashback galore and then whatever trope
it might be
uh where you know modern day character
gets to walk through past circumstances
of traumatic memories
usually that means like he's going to be
softer now he's going to say something
that's going to show he's really grown
and learned from what happened here now
i don't know it could all be like a
manipulation tactic because we've seen
that happen many times now where he says
something he lures friend to situation
we just saw recently
on the flip on the opposite side of
something more messed up with mother's
milk with soldier boy when he drugged
mother's milk like lured him in but then
had a secret motive and so it could be
the same thing
but you know with something positive of
like i'm just going to act like we're
going to get more v24 and then
really he's going to like hide him
somewhere or something
to make them dry out yeah yeah it could
be that that's gonna be the finales just
huey and butcher in a locked room trying
to sweat it out but i like the ending
choice
for the moment at least that it because
it wouldn't feel undercut if that is the
reveal in the next episode it won't
because in the in the immediate moment i
like the choice that also feels just as
human
for
him to not have learned hey because
that's real pets people in real life
yeah
the issue is the identity he has of
himself is as i am the one who destroys
the lives of people around me and of
course the nice thought is to
you know be like oh i'm aware of this
now and i will not do it but the reality
thought the real world is most people
just live off of the identity they have
of themselves which is if he the real
person would go i destroy
lives around me so i'm going to you know
whether i like it or not
and uh so i like the human
quality of that but like i said come
next episode if he's not really going to
do that i'm not going to feel like
something was cheapened out or something
like that because because it still hits
um yeah absolutely it's one of those
things too where you know you could
fully see him falling back into that
that trap of thinking that leaving is
going to help whereas the opposite of
helping or something like that pulling
away is going to help when it's not
well in homelander getting fooled by
starlight
surprise they didn't they just can go
and kill her
i was surprised that like this like coal
miner just didn't snap he's getting the
public back but that was so i should not
really move by starlight because i was
like it's even her i'm like he's going
to kill her he's going to kill him right
now no one's around snapping he's
loved that moment uh when she did what
about the phone and how he just like
panics at the side of that there's got
to be a way to spin the soldier boy
thing because now it's like
you know like as much as homelander is
the
the head of vaught now
and as much as homelander likes to
people's attention vaught is also in
some ways his number one enemy
for everything they did to him as a
child and and and to to now you know a
lot of it is
vaude is his enemy and vaught is also
soldier boy's enemy
so
you know like
you go on a whole rabbit hole of
predictions right now yeah
of what can surmise but as this show has
taught me to fear the worst
yeah i mean i think i think in terms of
week to week like this is the best the
boys has ever been yeah uh it is
i did re-watch the first two seasons and
so i like i think the first one is a
really tight
like i i love a lot of there's things
about season two i love more than season
one
um but i think season one is just a
great like solid first season like it's
pretty awesome
yeah yeah even though it has a definite
not a finite ending because of the
cliffhanger um
that is a great season this one though i
mean depending on how they landed so far
this is shaping up to be like this might
be the best one and i'm currently
feeling that and i love everything
they're doing with like every everyone's
so engaging and mm what he's dealing
with with trying to be a dad and i want
to bring it back a little bit more to
you know mm's motives here with soldier
boy because i feel like we've kind of
it's it it's it's never really seemed
like a
it serves as a way to get you worried
that something's going to happen at mm
but it's never really like even in this
episode i i kind of lost sight of that
like oh yeah he he wants to kill soldier
boy for what happened to his family like
i even forgot about it for in the moment
of watching this and i feel like that's
a very important thing that has to be
executed in some way not saying he has
to kill soldier boy but something with
that storyline has to feel fulfilled
something needs to give and i wonder if
there's going to be anything
any
[Music]
direct acknowledging or direct kind of
reckoning with the fact that they
at least like his daughter is being
slowly indoctrinated into homelanderism
by todd and just the environment that
she's in clearly mom is
probably at least somewhat concerned
about this but probably doesn't have the
reach to make sure that nothing happens
there and so it does make me wonder for
as much as his mission surrounds soldier
boy depending on what happens with
soldier boy and homelander it seems like
there i can see an inroad for him kind
of needing to stow some of his soldier
boy rage so that homelander perhaps
could be taken out which we assume he
probably wouldn't be but
again i like that mystery and i have
liked
his journey
across the show it's like even though
the most pertinent parts of his story
don't feel as engaged in an episode like
this
let's say i still really appreciate what
they're doing with him and it still
feels like part of a well-rounded
character's story and i do appreciate
that they have
two modes for him to explore you have
his past and his core wounds with
soldier boy but you also have the very
present that has to do with homelander
and his family and i find both of those
pretty engaging and now it's more like
i want to see him back with the boys
though yeah like i want to see him fully
fledged back with the boys and uh and oh
man just quick mention they're good at
two at like if a character only shows up
for one scene
or or like a couple brief moments
they're good at making those moments
have impact because like adrian
with that whole thing of like getting
blue hawks heart transplant and and like
i still don't even jordan peel [ __ ] i
know
and you're sitting there watching the
scene and that's a scene that i think
benefits from how brief it is because
i'm watching his performance and i'm
like okay i can see kind of the shock
and
horror but also i can absolutely see how
even here now in this moment you're
probably being suckered back in with the
well i could you know perform to the
best of my abilities again and i could
be back on top and i could have movies
and i could be hero and be on the seven
so yeah i'm like the fight for his soul
even just for that one scene like i feel
like that is the theme of that character
specifically is like every time you're
like you're so close to getting to
actual moral human levels
yeah pulls it right back
i
i i'm curious to see where they go with
that character uh
i am fascinated by because yeah
you described it perfectly on what
what they do with him because that i i
thought that was like
so disturbing what they did like it's
not a victory in the slightest
and to have these like
like
like
it it doesn't feel you know like they
brought up like the black lives matter
and they have done the commentary with
them but it's like you are seeing how
these corporate white folk are
controlling the life and narrative of
this black man's life yeah and just the
scope of cruelty
it's cruel it is it is even for h rate
i'm like
damn that is a cruel thing to do to put
this racist white man's heart in it and
and put it inside of he literally is
going to carry it with him yeah um
everywhere he goes how is he gonna speak
to his brother
god uh that is oh that is so that is so
cruel and like the way ashley has just
descended to
like
just so far down the rabbit hole
oh yeah corporate pr spin it is so it's
so disgusting so morbid and um i mean i
love the show for doing that oh yeah
yeah it's inspiring it's inspired
cruelty and it's also something that's
like outlandish but then you're like
well
i can see somebody doing this under the
right circumstances
you know to take an opportunity
you know keep up the company line and
except for the deep is just so
oh so embarrassing you think you'd have
some awareness that you probably would
not be into that like dude you you know
that people aren't into that like you
yeah
you i i'm surprised that deep never
found like a message board for that
i feel like you wouldn't know i feel
like there's something that seemed off
about the the
the character choice in that moment
because we've seen him in like uh other
seasons be so ashamed of just the fact
that he has gills on his body
and and two like any time he does
something sexual the fish this season
even is he's like a kid let her know you
know yeah he seems like furtive and he's
like he's trying to hide it and uh and
you know it's like i guess the argument
to be made is like he's been climbing
the ranks again and and becoming popular
again and and he
it's under the you know the disillusion
that he is
uh you know respected
what he's not
and so i can imagine that he's resorting
back with his old behavior now and
thinking he can just kind of get away
with whatever he wants and that he's
earned his way there and because he has
relied on his what's his wife's name i
forgot her name god i i wish i
remembered um i'd be props to her
because that's also like a as an actor i
i wonder what it's like to be that role
where so much of you is like the
presence and just like you know being
off to the side and encouraging but she
has such a presence well she's not just
encouraging she's manipulating yeah
controlling like and really
holding great interest in the outcomes
of all these things yeah yeah
ugh that's so gross i know are we going
to see i i mean we got to see that
hannity appearance
yeah yeah we gotta see what the deep is
like on his own um i'm gonna watch him
flounder
well
this is a wonderfully
wonderfully woven episode and uh oh and
black noir can't forget that you are
um this is his episode in a lot of ways
too uh
what information did homelander get from
newman
we never learned that right
yeah i don't think we did um yeah god
them too oh that was it take a shot of
liberals too
they were hungry i mean they're maybe
not as much but they're there the
democrats are the part of the same
broken machine
the third party
we need some alternative to this got the
one main character to do that towards
can you enact true change within the
system that breaks your back
i mean the black noir character has
always been hypersensitive and that's
kind of been like what's made him
likable is how sensitive he is in these
in these random moments like playing
piano or crying or something like that
yeah so i i i like not allergy yeah i
like how they're really like doubling
down on it but it's cool how they
brought it back into like a disturbing
formula again to see these flashbacks
but through child animation hand-drawn
animation
yeah it's messed up and yeah it's like
it's just the right amount of demented
because you're like well he was much
younger when all this happened and uh if
you had your brains brushed
i guess
you would crack a little too yeah
because you did see his face messed up
and then but you didn't see how that
happened yeah and so i think like as an
unveiling you know
like i think i think um
i think season two
of the boys
felt a little bit more like you have to
you kind of got to get a little bit more
of this
in a binge yeah like some some episodes
worked really well week to week and then
a part a big part of it felt like
you kind of needed more but since
episode one when they did release all
three this has felt like it could have
been week to week from the very first
episode
and i think this i think that's a big
part of what makes this season stronger
yeah than the others because
individually each episode is worth like
taking a breather from
and just absorbing what they did for
that one episode yeah each one stands as
a piece definitely um all right guys
well thank you so much for being here um
thank you to storyblocks for sponsoring
this video you can check us out on
patreon as well what did you guys think
uh leave your thoughts down below and
hey let's end this last but not least
patron of the day shut up
john
shout out ryan cross project if you do
not successfully know how to obviously
link this to the boys i will be so
ashamed ryan cross project ryan okay
listen so you
uh are the little boy
homelanders son and you're getting mad
ryan's a little bit cross but what if we
got ryan madd at the right thing that's
the project because if we can aim
ryan's anger in the right direction we
could get a leg up on homelander because
think about it he slags his son off in
speech but he's got a heavily some kind
of familial connection or bond
and and i think you would be a perfect
living embodiment of a you know more
grown ryan from the show which is why
i'm hoping we can parlay this here shout
out the other rank i assume your name in
real life must be ryan cross and the
project of this shout out is to get you
a guest spot as a flash forward version
of ryan on a future season of
uh
what's the spanish for a boy
um the boys i don't know i was gonna say
like uh los ombrace or something but
that's the friends
um you know
los ninos there you go los ninos that's
my project for you ryan cross i want to
see you
on the not so big but big production
value screen my dude my guy my buddy my
pal
hope you're doing well
and uh don't laser anyone's face off
could you do that
you did it thank you i tried
[Music]